hey let's make the most of it not today
maybe tomorrow you made an attempt on my
life brave perhaps but ill-conceived
[Music]
opening season very well
intelligence is a dying breed but not
today
hello everybody what is up gamespot live
we're back persia here and eric is
blessing us today i'm excited actually
and chat every single day you're not
here chat is like where is Eric so
you're welcome you guys got me but yeah
it's cool to be back obviously but glad
you and Richie have been able to kind of
like hold the fort down yes it's a great
time so yeah you guys of course if
Eric's on the stream then we're probably
playing some sort of FPS game of the
sorts which means today we're playing
apex legends because duo's are out
alright and this is like has been a game
type that everyone's kind of been asking
for a lot of yeah I'm this solo so I'm
kind of curious to see how this goes I
haven't played obviously oh wow I'm
level four I'm actually higher than you
that's the first so see I haven't played
the new map that much so I just know
that like capital cities like the spices
I guess yeah I think I'm more curious
over the fact that it's gonna be on
worlds edge instead of kings canyon so
Kings Canyon I would have been like
alright no problem
oh my gosh have mercy on us guys it's
kind of been a while I'm gonna I must
say first couple games of
you know like riding a bike better gotta
like relearn what I'm doing I think
they're brawler got buff like apparently
can like feel fast in the buff oiling
you know if they that's the last thing I
heard I I'm so behind I did hear about
that too like once you're inside his
shields you can use your equipment
that's or something like that so that's
actually a nice book yeah everyone's
like James back Bob Jones Brandon I am a
busy man or I'd like to think that oh my
god
go save you want to go spice yeah we
need to warm up oh wait yours I got
that's it
oh I put the fighter frightened oh
there's maybe one
definitely a one maybe two drew
I definitely heard a lot of people and
good for you someone threw something at
us
I feel like duos makes me want to stick
next to my partner more in the bar than
usual town yeah I will say though I've
been playing other games and I keep
wound up paying a great first start just
like we drew it up I was like I
literally had two bullets left in that
pistol no I was so sure I was gonna kill
the Mirage and then I just hear this
devotion spinning up behind you guys
we're warming up here don't you worry am
those hot plays are on their way
man Pathfinder is way slower really yeah
I am I just really felt the full force
of that change right now so I'm not
gonna pick him next game yeah you know
she's just like a jogging you know
you're like getting your legs warm yeah
I guess I mean I shot one bullet I was
actually you know getting the death out
of the way now so that later we're good
I do miss Kings Canyon though yeah [ __ ]
okay that's why I was excited that
Schneider was on there that's not a good
enough excuse
all right hey let's be big boys team big
boys big boy is patient on like life did
that uh yes Adam
we are who would have thought
[Music]
so so just punch me I don't like it
someone's still punching me somehow oh
yeah I heard there was a bug of some
sort like that going all right you're
John Matthews Oh again alright just got
to get that first kill out of the way
exactly let's go somewhere where my
traps would be real effective Oh spice
city alright I'm a lamest ink all over
the place
boom there's a lot there is a right
there's one group in front of us
that's going to man oh can I put a trap
up there
I like drop down somewhere boy sorry
guys we got some mother freaking weapons
this time oh man this mic is like all up
in my way we got feeling good oh yeah
because there was a lot of people here
for a moment and now I see no one I've
laid some traps I think we might be with
what am i great soon I hear looting
above me do kill leader heads up I don't
know how above me it was but they were
definitely on my the crap out of me and
I felt like I saw a lot of people yeah I
saw at least four squads drops this way
[Music]
while they're definitely going him over
to like the north side was that you oh
wait oh he dropped on me drop down yeah
he dropped down and went back up he's
trying to see where we are
did you bake yeah so here I have one of
those bad boys
oh yeah subject right here that's our
show what oh he's down here he just took
the thing back up the pot made sure I
did
[Music]
oh I got a milk oh the charge right all
right all right got a knock
feels a little bit better yeah I
literally did zero damage even though he
was stuck in my trap yeah that's weak or
maybe he triggered your trap and then it
didn't do anything all right gotta go go
back to free healing is this game
multiplayer only yeah
yes but they did add firing range along
with this update so it's kind of a
practice mode type thing yeah it's like
more in-depth than that opening area
that first time you got to do it so you
can mess around with different things
all right
by giving him
all right forget it that was just a bad
area uh maybe I mean let's go with Matt
I was actually just about to flank them
as you were we're getting like attacked
killed and then they both jump down as I
know I think if you linger in one spot
too long I keep getting hit here I know
I know how my bad aim also are Theo one
with 18 loads is this not as good as
what I have not had good choices lately
so like I said I think both of our
familiarity of this map is not great so
all right good for portraits on the
hotspot there's definitely one group in
front of us let the RAM have been bless
me I mean apex oops
I watched stream rants play this and
they have the best rng I've ever seen
well it'll get better once we like the
confidence that was me yep fine a
turbocharger yeah it was the [ __ ] the
altimeter literally had one good patch
to shine disruptor baby yes you so much
come back to me biscuits
we are good how are you man
[Applause]
warp out I am I'm trying I'm so I'm here
I'm chilling
go ahead is he still there he went
inside oh he's out watching your back we
got that Bangalore down though we're
making progress here except not me I'm
not at all did not hear that the person
behind that's a hot you know at first I
thought but you know they just slowed
these characters down but I just think I
haven't played in so long and I just
feel slower so I'm gonna maybe play like
octane or something oh just say go fast
yeah that sucks I don't even get to
shoot the other guy that's how bad it
feels
[Music]
what's a big difference you don't have
to build yep
which I forgot I mean bottle taneous
this one
oh I didn't feel like this games faster
then for tonight just depends though but
as purchase that you know build that's
like one of the biggest things and then
this game you have abilities so every
legend has like an ultimate it has like
a passive like an active you don't have
that important night what they did take
from this game in fortnight Earth Day
they have respawned buses now they
didn't have that before I think they
have painted to which they also took
from those to your face ping is amazing
yeah you really don't realize how much I
use it I was like I want a ping I can't
keep throwing grenades on accident come
on back right back
sounds good maybe not good I see like
three team stole up Wow like
I'm not going that way that's where they
are actually although here it's both of
you it's where we died this now yeah
let's see if this goes a little bit
better so far for me no because they
didn't get a good and once meet us after
it keeps giving me a long bow I do but
I'm like as the first weapon I'm like oh
man this is a lot of responsibility swag
on them tick thing or not we tick with a
flying one wait was that you that went
upstairs yeah okay yeah oh yeah that was
yeah I just heard climbing and I was
like I'm actually surprised by how quiet
it is oh there you nope I heard of yep
that above yeah I was like where is it
good
I definitely hear me so I'm just like
here are two sets of footsteps why don't
ya no fear all right where should we
move to I don't know I'm kind of like
I'm gonna go up and die probably up
right here
okay I'm gonna do at the bottom of the
zip yeah they're definitely just chillin
up there which is super wack I almost
wanna just let them stay up there
just peeking are they up there no I
don't see anything
Yolo it's like I think oh they use the
thingy though I hear feet under me oh
yeah I do too
I heard them for picking my orcs are the
sounds the tedious sounds the effects
legends oh yeah oh yeah one chart oh I
left
okay on the purple armor I tried to
phase out of there watching with one
shirt I should have threw some
pre-emptive grenades dang
I don't think pump you is first one yeah
h1z1 I don't know why that got why did
that get held for review
they don't make sense because it's the
word dumb the triple B's all right turn
to dig deep I know the odds of getting
to a gunfight just seems lower way I
must have missed the Simpsons before
that one yeah that like anticipation of
looking for them I'm not feelin area now
I still have not purchased a switch but
I will I will soon christmas is coming
up you know
all right we're fast and furious this
game no more it's got a run we're gonna
be on the move all right
our 99 is so wild back then is wild
I'm just not good good tomorrow - could
never really control that things go a
little slower game for the hot springs
yeah cuz everyone
now there's like teaching Bonet
we're okay over here
my god
oh they came out of nowhere
oh I'm entertainment just ran to the
other buildings I don't know why wrap
the back around into this one stop
talking and get in the game it's true I
believe it's a reset now you're in
trouble
nothing down there I was scared off link
China he's trying to park me yeah for
the past
sorry picking us he made us good luck
your pinch the sandwich
you knew that he's gonna run in meet you
there yeah my hope was that I was gonna
get a gun so I could find him I gotta
hop up in a backpack and then I was like
wow I'm dead good knowing you yeah
that's fine
it's just how battle rails go I know I
went from feeling super safe I was like
oh this is good drop and then
in three teams SuperSave drop is when
you drop like when the ship's about to
like leave the map in your yeah on the
other side the early ones on the other
side just two people left in this shape
finishes everyone okay now we drop no it
can't be anyone left
oof all right don't worry we're gonna
white one squad eventually and then
we're gonna like celebrate it like we
want a game
hey you guys take it somewhere I down
someone the same that was a big deal for
me
get the coffin in yes exactly that's a
it's a lead up you just haven't found
your main today huh I'm like looking
around taking too long this sweater was
a mistake
[Laughter]
people are punching I'm gonna charge
alright I'm gonna drop in like lava City
or something okay where do you want to
drop spicy
wherever yields the highest results of
success success oh wow there's still 26
people mission I know cuz they're trying
to go to that spicy area we're running
the back yeah in the hot springs oh
there's another group going alright
we're gonna destroy them yeah they're
like right behind me right now
[Music]
the Pathfinder no there's two squads and
they're fighting each other so like it's
safe to get you're not know never leave
anyone behind no grenades no problem a
wingman a PK the damaja here oh no
there's a group over there it's alright
it's alright you've already it picked on
my band room we don't have to go up
there charger we're good we're good
going through the mine yeah I can't
catch you too fast happy though IO
there's not a spot in you get some armor
oh there we go
where's the closest what's the
over-and-under that they followed me oh
I hear so much gunfire out there yes I
was like stopping to listen didn't do
the old Mele at the end canceled that's
I know flat animation I'm gonna use
those top tier strats oh yeah like
sliding by the thing okay I'm back
disregard the sound
HP
so far so good armor level one should
probably go get that med level three Hey
oh he's got charge uncle this guy
they're two of them how do you see me in
a smoke
[Applause]
hok job I choked I was intimidated by
his charge rifle oh man honestly I feel
like I've only seen very few people who
are actually that good all right all
right feeling better though feeling that
I should have just brought out the
wingman and wingman 'dom yeah but he had
a buddy right yeah if I killed that guy
there was a pathfinder nuts actually
psych myself I threw down the smoke and
then I couldn't even see anything either
and then Pat's
watch the flank it was too late I was
trying to win the 1 b1 and I couldn't
even do that
and I would have been excited if I could
have traded at least there I would have
felt less bad about myself
that seemed pretty good to be able to
run away yeah and like I feel like I
need all the vision I can get it now
alright progress we didn't die in the
first like X minutes well sorry you did
I did only because you got outgunned for
such a big map I'm actually shocked for
landing with multiple teams every time
well people are waiting to write it
maybe it's just an illusion and it's not
you know actually that big on the train
get any comfort in the fact that you are
now I'm like okay
[Applause]
okay okay
all right now shake it off
so pilots
the old Mozambique errs I swear they put
more of that weapon on the mat than any
other one I like the Mozambique if I
have the Wichita hammerhead shotgun
vault here level three again a light
extended mag new dibs
all right a nice slow pace and we're in
the circle yeah let's go
[Music]
I get looted all right see now we're
getting set here you got some goods so
there's less of an excuse now damn yeah
you might have anything what am I
waiting for I'm going in Achtung he's
like any more excitement I don't know I
was pretty stoked I'm living longer than
a minute
so even loot in this thing what happens
of the land and sellers dock here level
2 there is not much loot in this circle
I just got well then ok go back the
other way actually really like the Aria
45 it's pretty good
oh yes no excuses and it heavy back here
boy
Mesa let me know you can find a light
mags
alright this this is the game I hope so
this is the game I got a hold on you
guys putting on my trail oh you know
trusting in my seat
adjusting my form the lien for the lead
for the
we're like the next bootable icy area
yeah epic episode soldier 76
I'm Estelle cooler yeah I know that's
the concept but I rush way too much I
thought I was like maybe I should go
bloodhounds like a little bit okay man
we really did land far away from
everyone else I don't even hear a
gunfire she knows I just have this bad
feeling this is one of those games where
you're like cool I'm looted to hell and
then the first squad we see we die and
give them all I really now we really
have to win okay
I really hate this 2x scope I'm a hollow
or red dot guy same oh there's a package
over there
did we go get it oh no it seems like a
beat but there could be goodies let's do
it oh dang you're fast animal' Miller
it is like he's like over there
somewhere
nope that's a lie bold-faced lies
there's a flying leap tic thing too that
I forget the name for because it's not
actually Lou take it something else
yeah blue armor right yes there's no one
here and do I shoot that Lou tick-tock
oh that you like I haven't heard gunfire
the entire time I'm like really thinking
about shooting that ticker night report
no but I don't have an account at of
this thing
not that Oh yep purple armor and I have
energy and light but I did get a purple
light nice I know right bullets do I
switch to this is that purple I'm ready
for the short term mid but that's it I
can't fight long-distance so if they if
they like have snipers or Scouts or
anything like that
yeah have to move to the groove and rush
them down um where is the best place
that got I don't know to be honest with
you our little icy paradise over here
it's kind of in the direction of the
ring chillin nobody here uh I kind of
want to fight someone right it's like
zero or a hundred the same I like that
big that I have um no I'll give you one
oh I heard gunfire
okay oh I hear more gunfire it's for a
capital city it's always capital city I
sort of like I'll get so mad if I just
get shot in the back like as always
happens to run around forever oh it's
gonna happen just on the back let's it's
definitely gonna happen I can already
sense it I don't even remember my
call-outs anymore do I put that on my
Arthur you'll live if you have done with
the single show the map I got you yup
with that attachment it's over what all
right we gone single shot first quad was
your prophecy people oh there's a
package behind this oh I see them
they're running down the hill all right
what's the course of action I don't know
oh oh okay okay I see yep oh yeah
one is purple Armour we're gonna get
third-party dork up and go they're both
fair retractable receiver was a mistake
got make better or better aim than me
why did I pick up the anvil I would have
melted him with Norma or three I respect
the attempt though time I almost rather
job spicy only because like that's the
worst cool we wrote ran around for like
10 minutes got looted and died it's like
I said I told you i jinxed it alright so
hot drops every time and let's just
stick to each other like glue because
every squad that's taken us on has been
literally both of them next to each
other there's just me
that was I got melted by the charge
rifle so I got a the prophecy is real of
course it's real I first saw this
honestly the anvil is like if you had a
deal well my aim is not a point
especially with that um that scope I'm
so bad with the 2x I should like almost
never pick it up because I'm almost
better with like the iron sight you know
some of the guns have really good it's
not good
well let's do this we're going it
rightly
okay crime says I was next to you I was
near I wasn't like she means like
literally like yeah every time I Lynn
and then half the battle squad they're
literally both right next to each other
the squad drop in this way then oh
there's like two all right good maximum
focus
I need victims to know they went where I
wanted to go all right oh my god are no
okay I'm making my way towards you and
I'm trying to figure out where the oh
there's like someone right next to me
and we both don't have a gun so we're
just running away from each other
sick can I get a gun game there's armor
here on me there's literally no guns
here actually no guns
I got a stock hose now I hear a guy with
a [ __ ] shotgun oh that's okay we
should migrate yeah while they fight to
where oh here's here's guns go grab the
other one yes all right let's go get
some guns no one in our immediate okay
we can either go left and loot more or
we can go there's a dead box here all
right I hear a pathfinder coming to you
okay oh the Train is here but now what
did you smell
I'm sniffing I'm sniffing around
oh yeah space totally looted but is this
one of the stops that get a where do you
wanna go okay okay good
let these losers fight it out in this
free ride dear please know we have the
place all right let's go it's weird
alright this is now the Disneyland train
ride we're just inspecting our fun ride
next stop we are going to a thermal
station where the dinosaurs became
extinct you wanna hop out like right
here next stop on our left here you have
the Sonics where the you can have a hot
pack for all you stinky gamers out there
exactly oh we're leaving the circle
though yeah we should talk about now art
yeah and it looks unlit in noise alright
it was gold I had to get it give me a
key give us them to work were there I
was just a gold knock down his garb ah
hey play apex with one hand
amazing
[Music]
calculated all right no I don't want
that you know what I should change
because there was some hammer points oh
yeah yeah barrel stabilizer because I
hate us women oh nice yeah I could use
one
it's blue I know you saw someone now at
least it was me in a race they both had
nothing and we literally stared at each
other and then she turned around and
left
well we're in the circle I have double
precision choke sick take oh there's I
left a choke back there you want it I'm
in there you know where it is no it's
[Music]
way up high
he's shooting someone else yeah well I
didn't know if they're still down there
but they had the same idea I had which
is like let's just go up there and get
him
hey dying without shooting back at least
I can say like I choked or like he outs
killed me or she outs killed me get so
thirsty to like run faster though I
never have my gun out oh I should swap
dark
I should've swapped it out guys armor
that was that was actually the play but
I think we would have died anyways cuz
you're a low two right yeah I was trying
to heal same I was literally trying to
battery Anakin all right progress slowly
but surely
bloodhounds not the wave for me today
and they're baiting me the teeth the tip
was holster your weapon that's what got
me okay
Oh cuz you're running around yeah I was
like trying to run to the next building
and then Mirage sorry blow me up and I
had to like hide behind rocks like take
McKenna and turn around like No alright
they were help me out girl
we sniff them out or later Misaki get
your pump on yeah yeah ah all right it's
gonna be fine these pathfinders
good get in there slightly you get that
high ground I'll do it next game all
right
I don't know good question the less we
try to get there
company over there we remove their
shorts I wanna go there
everybody in the capital city okay well
we're not going there that's for damn
sure
oh you know what that Mozambique things
a paperweight of course if it had a
little bigger clip I'd probably use
across the way don't wonder I don't
remember that so devotion devotion here
I guess some armored game there's some
back here over there I hear gunfire
though party is starting in the city
that was coming from probably huh yeah
99 all right Mozambique it was yeah what
was that
it's not like someone jumped down rusev
it's okay don't think about it it's not
a person are we doing it are we going
into the city yeah let's go run these
fools pockets
oh they reviled in the city Wow bold
bold move
oh here oh I have a shot and there's
also down here too Oh jumping down and
there's another there's another one yeah
yeah I'm letting that one up oh he's one
shot and there's a guy on the stairs so
bad our third party action here oh and
the longest of cons here who's that
there you yeah just trying to make sure
nobody's flanking us what the heck it
was super hot over here and now no
they're still there but I'm running
along I'm already so what oh I am okay I
don't have the range to fight that right
away or I'm out of pole we've got eight
oh and there's a mr. left
oh that purple armor and I miss every
time the one I'll talk to you they're
pushing you Oh shucks
good luck they're both pushing you too
many choked wingman shot it's fun poking
at people at this couch I know we got
their party it's only a matter of time
until someone gets fed up with us being
up here exactly uh [ __ ] now it's going
fine that was only two squads that came
after a song right not the one and there
was still two chasing oh really unless
it just was one person it sounded like a
lot of feet am i right alright Irena so
go to like some caves or something ii
fled the area
what up evil ninja welcome we're getting
our duo's on struggling but it's
happening oh that guy should never get
another kill yet one three three seven
let's see here
want to go somewhere contains where's
the nearest cave
what's a cave over there suggest this
landing location meet a small space for
maximum stink the pathway I was worried
now it's like the medieval one the Dark
Souls 1
how did you go inside yeah definitely
actual jumping
what up Lauren Lauren maybe Loretta I
only have a peacekeeper okay I heard an
action over here but I think it's a
little deeper into the city so line here
I have like I already have a way down
lonely find you some armor
no I like new oh do I have a precision
joke if you would like it anvil receiver
hmm let's not do that Chad I don't have
a 301 oh you can see the blue armor is
warmer so oh yeah I see it yeah
you've got no armor coming into the
building okay shoot all right pop man
that's not what I wanted to do yeah he
left the building
like outside I think he went behind this
wall did he go what a magician keep eyes
on the new P leader he was just throwing
a thermite from back here oh he's inside
oh we like Judy
deployed no I went all the way up he has
blue armor this sucks
he's being so sneaky oh he's over here
now there's a bloodhound Oh easy and the
other guys on the ground so oh yeah I
think and myself is where I'm grappling
over do it hard that there's um he came
up here
should've left you as I was about to
take your like zipline over it he came
to Hollywood I could sense danger I was
looking for that guy for forever though
she's playing as caustic or was yeah let
them come to you yeah that could have
you know what though we tag-team that
bloodhound yeah I wanted to push him so
that we could Thurston
well yeah and the path was gonna go get
them so but then if that caustic wasn't
there I don't know I only know how to
play Kings Canyon it's all good I think
we're getting a better hang in the
strategy which goes stick together well
fought there I don't know that was
pretty bad
I'm reading kostik back again we will
see I probably did have my ol up there I
should be used
uh an oxen although I wouldn't have done
anything to the other caustic oh yeah I
think I set off his and I was still just
running around like little icy area
that's the closest group like a yeah
they went
first blood and it's not us wonderful
that chat is the the little like jump
thing not working a lot with a finer
where you can like really like rock it
yourself off grapple yeah they had a
vendetta against a character when they
when they through the patch their like
le zipping around way too much get out
of here fire no I'm coming back up here
when there's no loot up here
turbocharger let me just hold on to it
thank you so much it
I don't want to linger too long up here
select fire what do you want to go Molly
its words ice mountain over there okay
should play octane I've tried earlier
depends how far you graphic no I used to
be able to do this thing where if you
jumped right before it like hit the the
ground you could like really like it's
like fling yourself what changed it
that's how long it's been since I played
all right here we go
I think one squad landed over here
somewhere it's a car go by yep I see a
pathfinder over there my scope is just -
there I just saw one Pathfinder pursue
this to get its path and someone else so
if you want to let him left Oh morning I
will pick a shot this one this one
or why least okay I hate the triple take
ya know what saying we take the long way
around holders gold shield here you can
pick it up I feel like a useful in your
hands I got it I got a freaking triple
tick and a re 45 I'm pretty sure that
it's not gonna be better in my hands
well if you're sniping you have to be
able to take more shots we're going the
long way around yeah because if they
come up then we'll be able to see them
in theory the other way right oh you
want to go the other way no I was saying
they might come up the other way so one
says to come a little bit this is why I
don't winning any games of Apex this
logic right here they might have taken
off actually I don't have a helmet those
care packages likely shift the Delta in
our favor
independent variable at it
yeah they took off they're like I'm not
playing these games much y'all right now
well I'm stuck
I'm literally really I am so stuck jump
the other way yeah there we go
woo all right Oh scared where do you
want to go cuz I could zip us there yeah
I guess that's I'll zip over through the
city so we need to
oh we gotta get in there huh
Oh haze party happening going in oh it's
over there it's like in the Construction
Yard oh yeah I see it
I'm gonna run through the building
I'm on the ground almost cracked are you
just went into the circle oh he's down
here there's one more spot over there
got one there's one more right here at
the bottom Watson she's under you she's
climbing up the way you just came
oh there's another person what the hell
I know it's nice it was a race that
dropped that it's 741 that was the best
game yet yeah why snipe the Wraith and
then I was trying to get over to you but
then it was like too late
that was when Watson pushed you in there
it was like can't get the ear yeah I
should have moved towards you before I
tried every load should have been bold I
should just brought that triple take out
and try to snipe them on that oh just
like I'm like literally one shot right
now or I should have stayed high ground
yeah see no scope those fools yeah okay
take a 90 noscope
[Music]
that was pretty good I didn't seal the
deal music gamma squad squad number
where we almost got two squads one step
at a time
I wanted that skin I wanted that
caustics good but then I didn't play any
fighter fright which is a mistake use
was smashing out the triple take in that
one fight that earlier fight I did not
one distract all the other queens we can
try this depends if one of those is what
people are just team firing though
oh my god
all right to the spring as we go
maybe I was too early though there's
definitely another squad going man
unless they're over
there's a Mozambique over here oh yeah I
have one too this is sick
dude don't sell the Mozambique short I'm
telling you I'm about to bop someone
with it there's already 45 now this door
is open
I don't know why I'm following through
though wow they look the Peacekeeper and
here is the point is that you oh yeah
they're over there right here sorry not
like they're there like on the hill like
if you look through the door they're on
there Bharti Bop oh they're near the
mine now yeah
and then there's one there they're all
over there okay
shoot I wish I had a sniper Rana same
he's reviving so that one guys gonna be
low they're trying to loot though
a little alternator tap always buddies
right here
nothing like cleaning them up so what
I'm about the third party life oh my god
I get anxiety bleeding like this only so
it's good again today I only have two
short-range charged rifle in your that's
your thing no not really
no poke all right ditch this peacekeeper
oh oh that is definitely a person oh
there's an arc start behind me
watch out I'm closing the door
over there you oh can they come in from
here yeah but I won for the challenge oh
my god we gotta go pass them to get to
the circle are you sure time today let's
go
oh I just got ping it's fine okay I was
just seeing if he was gonna come over
incoming care package oh they're both
here just too salty oh he's a hundred
and he'll cracks
that corner that corner that red corner
I got it the other one might have
flanked us through the hallway I'm
getting killed by this hot smoke
[Music]
oh yes oh oh salty as ammo he ran
through the enzyme oh we gotta go
oh not like this no I'm healing off of
it whatever I got medkits gum that kids
for days meeting that kid I
I'm just gonna turn this around just
turn this one we take the guys are any
yeah we could yeah
butterfly okay maybe okay missed it
all right did you know you didn't die
though you didn't get a kill did you I
didn't I even threw my all like where he
was and ran and I was getting hitmarkers
but he was still alive I didn't get a
knock or anything
I was literally scratching my nose leave
me alone it's over there up there no no
second shot it would've got him that's
crap
I literally went to do this because I
like others we had an intense battle
like I was so annoying I was like is
this your trap no it's not your trap
[ __ ] dang sad never mind
yeah be careful well it was never a safe
time to scratch your lip okay
I got everyone we ran into you had like
well I guess everyone had a good shield
I said a white shield to the end
I stole the blue stick
Thank You Orhan I agree and we did do
some good work there before we had to
run to the ring
you're looking at a fighter who what am
I looking at
the lover
[Music]
hmm all right no Morris might be
determined unless is a triple take I
think I'm the best with the triple take
of a phrase right now
I thought longbow is your jam I just I'm
not much enough for that gun anymore
like I landed a whole clip party 45
switch landed the first shot of long
bone then he was like really close to me
at this way and I told he whiffs the
second shot oh crap someone's gone there
whatever we're fighting our way out of
it there's there's definitely a squad
and they're landing big house so I'm
gonna go a small house and hope that we
don't get out looted oh yeah a shotgun
bowl and a site prepared there's a lot
of loot in this building
[Music]
Oh
oh yeah I only ran through the bottom
floor yeah got the one in front of me
it's a yes I'm pushing here they're
shooting at the the thing okay Oh Oh
bait it bait it bait him into that
they're gonna come they're definitely
gonna come loot that thing right why
would you keep that and then not come
here
the other bolt here Oh
a good start a good start yeah Oh Unni a
presen joke I actually like without even
having a dream but it has that spread
boom easy it's good to get a W there
it's a small W that was coordinated well
we're in the circle so where do you want
to go Oh someone revived on the other
side of this building
it just goes farther I think all right
then the grapple goes farther
they're nothing that's not good oh we're
in the saunas or nearing there's a robot
take a look over there it's a cargo bot
I think that one might have a vault key
in it oh yeah there's a red dot and I
don't see that on any other ones you see
it yeah I did
it's making its way around town though
[Music]
we're doing a chat I have a hammer point
willing to risk it finish him off with
the Mozambique seeing I want that ball
to you yeah where'd it go oh just take
it then oh yeah it's getting further
this will be the death of us watch wolf
and I miss every time gold right I think
no matter what it will have one in it
you get it
no really
oh yeah this I thought this me all right
where we going we got the vault key yeah
we are winning in the loot life all
right
so doesn't it told you yeah there's one
right oh we gotta go through the geysers
for that one
oh boy this is exciting I've never
actually gotten a key oh boy here's
someone responding to the right of us
really or oh it might have been care
package
this is it now you you just jinxed it
this has been mooted at all you guys I
am so excited if I go in here and get
killed by campers waiting that would be
sick way to end it exciting times wow it
takes a few seconds to anticipate the
armor hey Carmen okay
oh you got gold helmet to you come on
yeah turbo charger now we're now we're
in business
yeah well cooking there's our pond Hey
all right end of camp it out squads
[Music]
I have to stall for you yeah we're
chillin in this cave oh this is in the
circle this is sorry time to shine oh if
you see extended energy are we staying
in here we should probably stay in here
yeah all right Chad I'll be here reading
your messages because we're literally
building a tent here the forits oh
there's a thingy um later too on the
other side that I could use to see if
there's um a beacon
it would be great if the final circle
landed here just saying was that you
opening paranoia at all time I all right
how's everyone doing we're just chillin
kind of chill to get that W you know
patients should not be that far from you
probably not got my my good old friends
the traps over here speed this truck
they'll never know
alright ap squatters left please let the
next string be here could be fantastic
15 seconds still happens anymore no I'm
good off no claymores in this game is
there a limit to how many Noctis traps
six
oh I'm over here just like planting them
all over
I am what will happen of course capital
cities like right there it's gonna end
in capital city I bet you I think it's
coming to us we have a good chance
do you want to try to run out there
there's a care package more trouble no
no no outside here not get baited I'm
not but that's someone's actual package
that's not really I thought that no the
blue one right yeah
nobody usually there more than one if
it's a blue beacon isn't that the game
won the world drop one I thought I
thought when the game drops that they
drop more than one care package at a
time that's true regardless we are good
right now man that beacon is so tempting
and like right there wait where's the
next circle not yet we're close to quiet
too quiet
eight squads left still 800 what was
that it oh they're definitely fighting
right I heard yeah they're fighting a
hair trip will take in to charge rifle
and someone definitely open that package
to our left up seven spots oh it's a
circle yes let's go all right I'm going
back to pitch the tent I have a ton of
traps on the other side so we'll know if
they they're coming in oh they're here
what side oh no I'm fine I'll come back
I want to put one like right in the
middle ish just because if they open
seven squads left come on pitching a
tent in this area all right or do we
want to like set up before it right in
the middle he right in the pit oh it
doesn't let you go up there hide in a
cross but I don't know maybe we
shouldn't have left that other door
though well you know traps so you'd know
well hide in the vault they'll never
know
I forgot it it'll take this is this is
great we caught this seems like they
gave up you're like let's go find they
probably went all the way around I
wouldn't put it past these guys I can't
tell I thought was your footsteps no I
think I was yours turn this up a little
bit even though it's gonna bleed my ears
I have come back to you yeah I'm just
making sure no one's coming in from this
way soon this door is not gonna matter
so it's definitely a wave the waiting
game y'all this is what it takes
sometimes to lose in a horribly sad
fashion
I hear charge right cool and like our
301 find ourselves inside the next ring
house your bolts are all now in care
package
I love loot movie someone must I had
hammerhead pistol 20 coin I see a
package dropping over there which might
mean my doors I bet you were gonna have
to get out of this hole champion out
please a pegs bless us
we got blessed by the vault here and you
you know
where do you think that all right all
right come on without to find out no way
it could be in here oh my god it's still
in the mine but what if it like closes
like outside you see that little town
yeah like it closes there are we screwed
cuz wait is it back the other way oh my
gosh okay I hear a lot of gunfire we're
getting close now way this is our tomb I
hear more gunfire over here though
they're like closer to that your other
traps Oh mine just went off so there I
think they're trying to push one just
went off oh yeah they're here I'm coming
I'm trying not to
Claire yeah maybe back up because they
have to come this way right mm-hmm oh
they're here yeah we'll just set up
another for it there's a fake Mirage
right here I hear so much oh no they're
right there with enemy near the little
barricade recharging shields well
they're in the circle now though no
we're not yet they're in this holiday
will be a little bit recharging shields
[Music]
we're inside the next ring positive
result they just triggered one of your
traps gas trap
and we're gonna get the old sandwich
here I'm moving on but I just have a bad
feeling there's five squads dr. Boyd
they just killed your trap by the way
it's fine waste that ammo okay where's
the next circle oh we got to get out of
here we should just go I think yeah yeah
I think so because we get stuck fighting
then we're never getting out of here oh
yeah they're pushing in now that's okay
they missed all their shots on me oh my
god it's just so bad are we going now oh
there's someone there but he's fighting
someone and there's someone down below
to you at that same building there
there's two on the top do I jump up or
do I chill
kill the one
[Music]
[Music]
they're fighting a squad car and there's
in the key
three squads so it's that lifeline above
and then that that's why huh I see them
just watch our lifeline uh you should
shield up to me have a second 49 seconds
oh there's a race they're fighting yeah
someone pushed out I'm looping this
rocket you love fest oh we're dead
aren't we
I'm trying to be nice kid it's all
that's all for me I got one second
that's great
so they're 2r1 isomerizes only one I've
seen so far all behind me one guy's nice
I'll try to give your eyes yeah one be
one right there
come on Trask come on trap oh that's how
you do it that's how you do it it
communicate and then pray to Jesus I was
praying really hard truck no but that
lifeline teleported on my screen it was
super weird except I saw you triggers a
trap and then you're like she like went
this way it doesn't matter oh lordy
Lordy sweet baby yes Evan hey we
struggled all day the bulky and the
bulky 100% oh man that was great
whoo I got my I was like excited to
high-five you but my hands are also so
sweaty we can't do it I've got a trade
and hope for the best workout oh my
goodness that was a match I'm glad we
lost all those matches to win that one
at the end yes the underdog story that
was definitely great thank you guys so
much for supporting us the entire way
excellent
yeah costing the boy the boy anywho
thank you guys so much for tuning in
watching us get that dub you and hey go
play duo's it just came out yesterday
and it's pretty cool definitely
communication heavy strategize cuz if
third partying and fourth fighting and
fighting I feel like that's massiveness
so yeah thank you guys so much that's
gonna be it for us today and tune in
every week day 11 a.m. Pacific time cuz
that's playing a game spotlight be
poppin and we'd love to see the comeback
in the meantime have a good one we'll
see you later
see ya